bit of a difference I think they make a
difference to momentum I think it just
helps the general feeling or whether
you're up or down and also I don't know
what own things I think it's a bit of an
unfair playing field I think that people
are kind of surprised if celebrity comes
out in support the Tories so it's an
easier pitch further right and people
are quite shocked often if an artist or
a celebrity is against the left i think
frankly the Conservative Party would
have been an easier time of it what
about Owen what do you think well it
depends who the celebrity is I mean no
Gallagher saying doesn't support labour
anymore it's not new he's been saying
this for years and years I mean no
seeing how you left the back door down a
street in 97 he was pretty fed up with
what Tony Blair was doing and then you
look at the kind of people that
authority of god I kind of agree with
Alex here they are there they're cool
Britannia mark to party last year and he
was invited Bruce Forsyth cilla black a
look at what's on the name's Ronnie
Corbett I mean these are not people that
are going to inspire people to come out
and vote particularly national treasures
Carolyn day what do you think I think
that's right i think that celebrities
can have a huge influence on momentum i
completely agree with that and i think
that they they shape the brand if you
can look at it that way and I think we
should of a political party of a
campaign and I think it depends which
celebrity it is and maybe at which stage
of their career they are no Gallagher
maybe doesn't have as much influence
these days although he's got a new album
out next month but not as much as he did
during the Blair era so if it were
somebody that commanded far more crowds
I think it could have heard a lot more
than maybe mean for mike russell brand
perhaps yes or well who has interesting
example who has his own controversies
but say someone I'm making this up right
now say someone like ensuring that
everybody loves and is really hot right
now that I think could have been a lot
more damaging I'm in front of
politicians part of you is better to be
endorsed than not to be indoors which is
what Russell Brand Stanley basically
said you're all rubbish yeah well then
said he might stand himself having said
he doesn't think you should vote at all
which would be an interesting campaign
right the none of the above campaign for
me one of the interesting aspects of
celebrity endorsement which may make a
difference is when celebrities take a
position or well-known figures take a
position on policy say for example when
James Dyson who is I think quite a
respected person in the public eye
said that in unbalanced he favored
coming out of the European Union that
got a lot of attention people were very
surprised that someone in business was
willing to take up a standpoint like
that that can make a difference and
dragging an issue up the agenda I mean
Carolyn what do you think that ant and
DEC's speaking out and not only people
that do and they do have a huge
following and they are sort of saying
things that I think a lot of ordinary
voters also say that potentially very
damaging because they're seen as perhaps
being as more authentic than politicians
I think that's exactly the power of
celebrities they have a unique ability
to connect with people and because
people are used to seeing them they
relate to them and they almost feel that
they know them and that's the influence
that they have it's a it's not I think
that there is a discussion about policy
issues those things get much more
technical but things that really hit
home in people's everyday lives i think
is quite powerful what do you think I
mean I mean to a certain extent now we
we just expect that every party will
produce its lift the list of celebrities
wasn't even the liberal democrats that
calling forth in the last election I
mean it are we now a bit neutralized in
a bit jaded about celebrities well even
at harry potter is well Daniel Radcliffe
from the last election I think we are I
think we realize that celebrities are
kind of you know what they got bested
interests who's come out against the
mansion tax Sol Campbell myleene klass
these are people who kills the priests
have got mansions so I think that we do
sort of realize now these celebrities
and not just speaking because they never
got a view of how they want the country
to be better I mean Ant and Dec is seen
as authentic sure but these are guys
that have spent 20 25 years in show
business that's not what a lot of people
spend their career doings I think there
is a little bit of a credibility to hear
these people come out you've got a look
at all of a sudden well they're they're
not speaking from where they were and
they were 80 they're talking in their
40s now a little bit more money bit more
success is that what they're saying
these things I don't know I the reason I
question that is if they were saying
something that didn't chime with
people's general perception then I
reckon that would be right but when they
say they have a question not about the
Labour Party but about Ed Miliband
specifically that I think chimes with
the main problem a lot of people who
might otherwise be inclined to vote
Labour have when they think about where
they vote in the next election and it's
when that happens when they hit a kind
of the common objection to that party
that's when I think people like Anton
Zeck you
she just feel like they still got the
common touch that I think is when they
cause a problem for politicians and it
is a problem for Miliband I think Karen
I mean ed miliband is actually responded
to this saying he he is sure he can win
Anton back do you think he can knit
though what she'd be doing ah that's a
it's a tall order isn't it um I I think
he'll be working very very hard now to
to show that he can do it and that he
has done it I if I had to bet right now
I think that's going to be really tough
all right I just wanna see you Karen
start with you who would be the dream
endorsement do you think for Cameron or
indeed for medevac well and if we're
going for celebrity and I mean celebrity
nothing to do with politics just in
terms of who was crowds and big huge
crowds and his beloved i mentioned
earlier a poor him i don't know why i'm
thinking of him right now but ed Sheeran
is would be the dream endorsement what
are you right now in well I guess you'd
want one direction but then not many of
their fans can vote so maybe perhaps you
wouldn't be pushing too hard to get
Larry nicely I say for the Tory party JK
Rowling unexpected strong woman
background that might imply off the left
very interested pull it in politics and
with an her target audience is just
coming up to vote for the first time so
I say JK run they're not going together
there I think she's not your dream yeah
I think I big about thank you all very
much to me thank you